please can I have some advice for
dealing with poor leaders at work they
have little respect for and a question
as a subordinate how do you handle a
leader who leads from a place of ego and
isn't transparent with information yes
so these were a couple questions
actually that I got and I just kind of
bunched them together because my answer
is gonna be very similar for each of
them and it's actually very similar to a
situation that I'm dealing with right
now the chasm helping out and I wrote
something to him
recently and what happened was he's in a
situation where a leader had come in
that didn't have the knowledge inside
the industry they were working in so he
came from another industry got put into
a leadership position and that guy that
new leader was resisting change and not
giving support to the new procedures
that the guy was coaching was trying to
implement so he was kind of you know at
a loss for what to do you know you got
this new manager that's coming in that's
inexperienced and he and the guy I'm
coaching obviously doesn't respect him
because it doesn't have a lot of
knowledge in this industry and so here's
the advice I gave I said you need to set
this up to make the new manager look
good make some adjustments to the words
you are choosing the tact you are taking
and the focus you are using to ensure
that your changes make him look good not
bad now this is so counterintuitive for
people it's so counterintuitive cuz they
gets that person that's above them in
the chain of command that doesn't know
as much as them that's not as smart as
them and what do they want to do they
want to bring them down they want to
prove to everybody that they're better
I'm better than that guy they drowned
that guy I deserve that guy's job that's
what everybody's instinct is to do mm-hm
and it's wrong it's wrong
somehow let the ideas come from him or
make him the approver or the driver of
some of the s aspects that he can handle
so I'm actually saying go out of your
way to make this easier for this guy
make him look good give him credit it's
your ego that wants to pull him down put
your ego in check
help him without being condescending or
acting like you know more than him he
shouldn't even know you are helping him
have you ever been this is so fun to do
is when you know EKKO doesn't know this
section of the equipment mm-hmm so I
don't say hey since you don't know this
I'll teach it to you right this
condescending tone of you know but
instead of like hey have you ever seen
the way this one works I know you have
you ever seen this specific equipment
before because the way it works it's a
little bit different than some of the
other ones is you got to do this this
and this and you can sit back and you
can accept that knowledge without
feeling like you don't know it right so
I'm teaching you but I'm doing it a
clandestine management and that's what
we're trying to do because we're trying
to build Oh charity we're trying to
build a relationship here that's what
we're trying to do we're trying to build
a relationship and if I go since you
don't know how to use this I'll show you
now what does that do put you on the
defensive makes you considered me to be
a threat now I'm threatening and that's
not good he should even know you are
helping him respect what he does and
show him that you respect it so hey you
know I know this is you probably haven't
been down the weeds on this type of gear
in a while but hey this is the way you
don't know saying like you actually I
actually respect the fact that you're up
top in charge and I'm just a frontline
guy but here's how you do this if you
ever add to right you know what I mean
just downplay what he doesn't know and
subtly help him to learn it right you
know you probably would never have to do
this this this new equipment over here I
mean I know it's a little bit below your
level here's how it works if you ever
needed it boom you don't mean not like
you don't know how to do this right
you don't want an adversarial
relationship with this new leader you
want him to support and help you he will
do that if you are making him look good
this is so easy man
this is so easy and so hard because
everybody's ego will get in the way
everybody's Eagle will get in the way
extreme ownership often requires covert
and clandestine indirect actions so all
these things that I'm talking about
helping the guy without him knowing
letting him take credit for ideas
without him knowing all these little
aspects they're indirect actions they're
not going head to head it's like jujitsu
it's jujitsu all the time
everything's jujitsu you don't want to
if you know I'm gonna do an armbar
mm-hmm I'm not gonna get the armbar
right you're gonna defend that so I have
to go take indirect actions and set
things up and take my time and be
clandestine and covert this is chess not
checkers this is where you need to
master your ability to influence which
as we talked about a little couple
podcasts ago is actually manipulation
I'm manipulating this guy to think that
he's got something over me I'm inflating
his ego while I'm putting my ego in
check I'm making him feel like he's even
better and that makes him feel good it
makes him want to support me because I
make him look good this is this is just
basic if you do this wrong the new
manager will resist you at every turn if
you do this right he will be your
biggest supporter now this is the same
thing with leaders that you're
quote/unquote don't respect first of all
there should be something that you
respect about everybody everybody that
you meet you should have some kind of
respect for them and by the way if you
don't respect someone what is making you
not respect them hmm it's your ego it's
your ego that makes you not respect
people because you think oh I'm better
than them I should have their job
they don't know what they're talking
about and I do mm-hmm
that's all ego so put your ego in check
and just be like okay this person's
above me they seem really inexperienced
but what can I learn from them how did
they get there if they're so dumb and
bad at this job how come they outrank me
mm-hmm let me learn something from them
let me learn something from them
put your ego in check and this is the
key point and any time I talk about
quote-unquote leading up the chain of
command I will talk about this that no
matter what boss I work for and I work
for every different kind of boss
egomaniac psychopaths wonderful guys
intelligent guys brilliant guys
tactician
I work for every different kind of boss
and I always had the same relationship
with all of them that was my job was to
build that relationship and that was a
relationship of high trust so they trust
me they were to stay out of my way and
let me do what I wanted and that's how
you win which by the way when you win
they should never know you win they
shouldn't even know that there was a
competition happening and that way you
can do what you want and so that is how
you deal with people above you and the
chain of command that you have little
respect for or that lead from a place of
ego you build a relationship with them
you don't go head to head with them
you're not gonna win going head to head
with your boss they're your boss they
have rank on you if they're an egomaniac
they're gonna use that rank mm-hmm if
there's someone that you don't respect
you gotta build a relationship with them
if there's someone that's an egomaniac
you gotta build a really regardless of
the situation the solution is the same
build the relationship of trust help
them build them up take a back seat let
them get credit it's all those things
and once you do that you're gonna have
you're gonna have much better results
than if you try and bang heads with them
overcome them defeat them have an
antagonistic relationship with them it's
never gonna work mm-hmm
so play the game